les incidents qui suivent
m'ont été décrits exactement tels que je les présente ici et
d'une manière tout à fait inattendue dont l'
alpha est intéressant ne le reconnaissez-
vous pas puis-je vous inviter à dîner avec moi
ce soir et il me fera plaisir de
vous raconter mon histoire
soufflons qu'il manque quelque chose et dans l'ordre contient cet inaud
représente je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais
il y en a des traces et des ombres
partout personne ne dit que c'est une promenade
sur une promenade bordée d'arbres mais la belle
dame dans un bouton de portail blanc Scott quoi
vous appelleriez vulnérabilité, je crains que ce ne
soit la dernière fois que nous nous voyions
bien après que ce soit le cas, je le
convertis en mots mais je sens qu'ils
menacent ma vie et maintenant ils ont envoyé
ma seule famille non qui  ils tuent cette
fois son corps a été retrouvé enfermé dans un
sarcophage derrière une salle de stockage et un
musée de chattes tard hier soir il était
court quatre doigts lui dit Jopling
dit rentre à la maison jolie photo arrête je ne peux
pas t'aimer très cher souviens toi de la fenêtre dis
non  un ils expliqueront tout ce
qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé mon cher zéro est que j'ai
battu la merde vivante d'un
petit avorton pleurnicheur appelé pinky bandits key tu
devrais jeter un long coup d'œil à sa vilaine tasse
ce matin
il est en fait devenu un cher ami